yeah just put the ham sauce and do we
have room in the freezer now just put it
in the fridge uh yeah oh oh [ __ ] my
[ __ ] live sorry guys all right um
what psychobabble I can say [ __ ] in
there that I'm listening to me um yeah
so we're gonna do I I guess I Pierce's
party time ma'am yes sorry you guys had
to hear that pledge card think I found a
new place here's you were supposed to be
looking for l'wren not going house
hunting see that's the beauty of this
place it's owned by the morning star
listening the morning star have a
penthouse downtown with its throwing
some big party for their global kinda
Study Center for real estate agent will
be there real funny I was gonna say we
crashed a party kill the morning star
and keep the place for the faint good
what's the plan the things will be
downstairs until you can unlock the
elevator for them to come up wait if I
can't go up then how light oh right
penthouse that's right Mimi airborne oh
that's kind of dope um anyway yeah so um
if you're wondering like I know like you
know towns talking about a ham sauce and
like people didn't know it was it's kind
of a prize so that's your case I feel
bad for you but I guess I might as well
civic duty to talk about him
so you might wondering like what what is
ham saw psycho like and what is that
like again I get the sauce in the hand
part but like what is it well well yeah
Tuesday let me just explain to you how
ham sauce is what you get sorry just
take a little shortcut um ham sauce is
like if you ever cook like a lot of ham
like I don't know to help have the ham
like you know afterwards like it's
cooked but there's like some sauce at
the bottom of that ham sauce and if you
let's see here another way to get ham
sauce and this is the way I did just
because it's easier and I'm already
gonna have the hand like if you have a
lot of ham like talking like 45 pounds
or more um then you just like store it
like a edius it's like a tub where
container or something you know and just
let like it sit there for like wigs and
weeks in like some liquid accumulate set
that's ham sauce like believe it or not
the damn sauce and what I do with it
like I'm you know I'm kind of an Aikido
kind of guy keto diet pill Olympic so I
poured into like a to-go cup but just
like I'll drink some later like it
drinks I'm here like I'm all about that
like fitness um so yeah I guess I you
know I don't storage dings the hardest
part probably because you don't want it
to congeal there's not too much hope you
like jerking congeal but I don't want to
congeal illness and make a chapstick or
something you know so but yeah yeah
that's a basically ham sauce I don't
parties on social things
what you thinking
some [ __ ] is in my
the crews ready downstairs say the word
and we crash the party
Teddy I tennis okay I'm sure you clear
can I just Lance straight in the water
why do I agree to this [ __ ]
oh I guess you can't I'm gonna land in
the [ __ ] love it I always win my
touchdown oh sure I'll get the elevator
code and let you up soon just give the
work on
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that's gonna stop
right I think that's so funny when
people i think that that's gonna stop me
cuz it's not Oh get the graphic the
freight elevator give me the code go to
hell that really how you want to play
fine codes 3131 just watch the jacket
wow he's gonna love this place 31 there
ain't one I'm just a pretty face I'm
like such a maverick I got sometimes it
just makes me laugh yeah okay I'll read
it oh good oh good nades look problems
can't you saw Pierre should go through
this [ __ ] later
over there I'm nothing fancy cut Cohen
ham sauce party crashing time kinda
doubt take the door clear ok mate Claire
baybay ok bay Claire that Claire I'll
remember this one ouch is [ __ ] me
what's the plan here we mop up the rest
of these [ __ ] easy enough
this is the best one cover me your
weapon should be loaded oh sorry [ __ ]
son good shot I snap the neck batches
thank you God
come on bets let's take a little swim
kick ass
oh okay okay we're gonna do this the
good old-fashioned way batches that he
is gud gud gud gud gud
not shed this more guys
mean updates on be good news we've
cleared him out oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
the boys are saying this place is rigged
to blow isn't that fun where's that guy
in the helicopter going I'll ask him how
to disarm that thing then try not to
kill him okay let's do this [ __ ]
does it clean I'm going far away look
like the damn made you look cute in the
ass we're setting on a bond here and
you're making a joke peers would agree
with me about the [ __ ] smashed as
[ __ ]
set
and this [ __ ] gon
oh [ __ ] I am falling out who's the
second shooting rockets that right I ass
[ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
I'll on him
akumal on him now where is he going oh
[ __ ] shut
looks like these things are on a coating
dimer and the clock ticking you got them
yet inside catch him you'll get your
cones nope no codes just four wires red
green blue and black and its original
chases how do I get this [ __ ] everyone
out of my way hi I'm Scott which wire
stops the bomb the red wire cut the red
wire thank you God God yes chef oh it's
happy to shop someone should not away
from here
Oh
Red Sean D yeah a lot of bed oh [ __ ]
okay that's easy the Saints aren't going
to back down Maddie there's nothing to
worry about my thoughts exactly mr.
Cuban the Saints are no more than a
white noise at empty sites like that
with respect sir I'd say our gun is no
longer applicable that's a cough did
those boobs there's a better Hey well
anyway I'm thanks for watching guys I
hope you like it
it's out for Harambee